exploring other planets is one of
mankind's most cherished dreams
at the very beginning of the space era
enthusiasts were certain that in the
21st century
our closest planets in the solar system
would be thoroughly explored
in reality however things proved to be
much more complicated than expected
and so far apart from the moon and the
earth of course no human has set foot on
the surface of any other celestial body
many believe that manned flights will
not pay
others doubt if they'll be in demand
still there is a good chance of visiting
other worlds
and it's closer than may seem at first
glance
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
the american company spacex is one of
those who are essentially the tip of the
spear
in space exploration this private
commercial organization was founded by
elon musk back in 2002
six years after its foundation and after
a lot of research and a number of failed
experiments
the falcon 1 launch vehicle developed by
spacex engineers
successfully went into our earth's orbit
for the first time
this was proof that space exploration
doesn't have to be in the sale domain of
the state
in the 12 years since its first
groundbreaking success
spacex accomplished over a hundred of
successful launches and also delivered
tens of thousands of kilos of useful
cargo both to the iss from the earth and
the other way around in total
in addition since 2020 the reusable
spacecraft crew dragon has been on two
successful flights to the international
space station carrying astronauts on
board
it goes without saying that the spacex
company is advancing by leaps and bounds
one may debate the reasons of its
dazzling success till the cows come home
but this is rather pointless and unduly
disrespectful
let's better direct our gaze ahead into
the future
and envisage what fantastic achievements
we may be looking to witness
as soon as the nearest decades
[Music]
spacex is currently working on three
main tasks in space exploration
first and foremost it is an
international project of a manned flight
to the moon known as artemis
which they are working on in
collaboration with nasa esa
canada japan and a number of other
countries
also work is underway on the global
satellite internet constellation
starlink
that provides high-speed satellite
internet access
last but not least a manned mission to
mars is currently in the pipeline
the programme artemis aimed at exploring
the moon was announced by the u.s
government in 2017
it is suggested that the project is
broken down to at least three stages
with the start of the first one planned
for the end of 2021
it involves orbiting the earth's natural
satellite
using an unmanned spacecraft with its
subsequent return to the earth
at the second stage a crew of four
astronauts is supposed to orbit the moon
without landing on it
at the third stage planned for 2024
four astronauts are supposed to land on
the surface of our earth's satellite
the upcoming mission to the moon may be
seen as a practice run
and the first step to a manned flight to
mars within the framework of the artemis
project
the super heavy rocket booster and the
spacex starship will be tested in real
conditions
moreover a space station is planned to
be created in the moon's orbit
which may become a stopover platform for
travellers bound for the red planet
in the next 12 months spacex will have
to launch its spaceship to high and low
altitude orbits
in order to see how to adjust its
construction to perfection
these flights will include scheduled
cargo delivery flights to the
international space station
as well as launching communication
satellites into the earth's orbit
eventually starship is supposed to
supersede the currently used falcon 9
and falcon heavy rockets
the new generation spacecraft will be
able to boost up to 100 tons of payload
into orbit within the course of one
flight only
at the same time the cost of one kilo of
cargo is supposed to be at an all-time
low
mars is at its closest point to the
earth once every two years
obviously it makes sense to take
advantage of this position of the
planets
as it is the best and most convenient
for traveling from one to the other
the nearest time the planets will be
their closest point is in the summer
2022
this is when two unmanned cargo
spaceships are scheduled to be launched
on their way to the red planet
it will take them from several months to
one year to reach their destination
their mission will be to deliver around
100 tons of cargo to the surface of mars
power supply facilities mining equipment
automated machinery and a lot more
the main objective at this stage will be
to reconnoit to the ground
to search for water ice and to take care
of infrastructure for future colonists
remotely operable machinery will lay the
groundwork for safe landings of future
crude missions
for example it will need to clean the
area from rocks which are potentially
hazardous
and to carry out geological prospecting
particularly focusing on finding water
ice
which is vital for future colonists
survival and generally for developing a
settlement
water isn't only a substance vital for
any biological life forms but it's also
indispensable in the electrolytic
reaction that produces
oxygen and hydrogen as it runs its
course the former is needed for
breathing and for burning fuel
and the latter may be transformed into
methane when coupled with co2
methane will be used as rocket fuel
the following stage of mars colonization
is scheduled for 2024
this is the next time mars will be the
shortest distance away from the earth
to be more exact approximately 57
million kilometers
all in all four launches are planned two
cargo flights and two
manned flights the spacecraft will
travel for several months
and reach their destination in 2025
shortly after they get some distance
away from the earth
it will be impossible to catch up with
them so in case of unforeseen
developments they will be left to their
own devices
with no assistance from the earth to
count on
spending several months on a flight in
interplanetary space is quite a tough
ordeal
there are many important and complex
tasks the constructors of the crude
spaceships will have to handle
not only will the available room have to
be used as efficiently as possible
but will also have to provide conditions
good enough for the journey to be
comfortable and
safe the expected number of the crew is
several dozen people
they will have both private quarters and
common areas
as well as gyms to help prevent unwanted
changes in their organisms that a long
stay in a weightless environment may
cause
in addition a large portion of the
payload bay of the ship will be occupied
by storage rooms
various equipment and life support
systems
protection from radiation is a crucial
point in interplanetary travel
as the rocket will be pointed in the
direction opposite from the sun for most
of the journey
the living quarters are planned to be
located in its front part
thus the storage rooms and other
sections not intended for the crew to
stay in permanently will be taking the
brunt
absorbing most of the harmful solar
radiation and so shielding the travelers
from it
the main goal for the red planet
colonists will be to build up a martian
base with adequate conditions
where humans can stay for prolonged
periods that includes creating favorable
conditions for growing plants
and deploying machinery and equipment
for producing oxygen and rocket fuel
even though it may sound rather fanciful
elon musk claims to create a
fully-fledged martian colony by the end
of next decade
at the latest this colony should be able
not only to remain autonomous for
prolonged periods
but also successfully develop
however the settlement on an alien
planet may encounter unforeseen problems
and suffer from their dire consequences
the project biosphere 2 is an example
that illustrates
just that within the framework of this
project a balanced biological system was
supposed
to be sustained under a sealed dome the
experiment showed that creating an
isolated ecosystem is an elaborate
process
fraught with unforeseen pitfalls the
longer the short of it is that the
performance of the ecosystem used in the
project
wasn't up to the mark as a result the
system wasn't able to provide the
potential settlers with either oxygen or
sufficient amounts of food
another danger to be reckoned with is
cosmic radiation
mars is devoid of a magnetic field which
would protect its surface from cosmic
rays
that is why radiation protection should
be high on the list of priorities when
constructing the base
even so there still remains a
perceptible threat the mars explorers
are exposed to
cosmic radiation may cause intoxication
and general weakening of the settlers
organisms
as well as raise the risk of getting
infected and developing tumors
another challenge that should be taken
into account is psychological
compatibility
or rather incompatibility of the
colonists conflicts are to be expected
in an isolated community
which is a well-known phenomenon in
psychology it's referred to as cabin
fever or confined environment psychology
which is manifested in heightened
irritability of the members of an
isolated group
tempers become frayed for no apparent
reason and the consequences may be grave
with the parties fighting it out and
even sustaining physical injuries
let's hope that ways will be found to
handle this unpleasant phenomenon
it is quite probable that first
colonists will never have a chance of
getting back to their native planet
disconcertingly martian colonization is
also likely to involve human casualties
still elon musk has made a pledge to
develop the first martian settlement
into a real city by 2050.
this should be facilitated by the
development of an interplanetary
transportation system
which is something spacex claims to have
in the pipeline as well
time will show whether it will work out
or not
of course today talks about a martian
city have an air of science fiction
about them
but come to think of it just 100 or even
50 years ago
talks of many things we're now familiar
with would appear to be flights of fancy
mankind is constantly forging ahead and
new research results and discoveries are
announced by the scientific community
every day
that is why the chance to travel to mars
is real
if not for us then for our descendants
but of course it's up to every
individual to believe
how big this chance actually is
let's keep in touch
[Music]
oh